sujets qui posent le plus de questions
également ce fameux pas sanitaire qui
devrait nous permettre d'avoir une vie à
peu près normale
c'est quoi le pass sanitaires alors
c'est demain déjà ces deux mamans déjà
demain commence demain c'est important
c'est un code que vous aurez sur votre
téléphone pour ce combat de téléphone
comme ça une feuille de papier ça marche
aussi
d'accord ça vous permet d'abord de faire
des activités en france par exemple
aller à roland garros voir un match de
foot aller voir un festival cet été un
concert des activités de plein air de
plus de 1000 personnes
d'accord c'est pour ça qu'on utilise et
quand vous êtes vacciné ou vous avez
faire un test si vous n'êtes pas encore
vaccinés d'accord vous avez le code et
vous pouvez rentrer dans l'événement
cela permet de rouvrir un peu plus vite
et puis c'est utiliser ça me concerne un
peu plus pour voyager à partir de demain
on pourra voyager en europe
si on est vacciné je mets les plus
facilement et nous en france parce que
évidemment on l'a dit touristes et on a
envie de les accueillir on a envie que
les français restent en france le plus
possible on a envie d'accueillir des
gens qui viennent de l'europe et du
reste du monde mais de manière sûre pour
pas que le virus soit réimporter
circulent et avec ce pass sanitaire avec
la preuve de vaccination on pourra
commencer à accueillir principalement
des européens aujourd'hui
d'accord vous vous êtes vacciné ou pas
moi j'ai une dose d'accord de la dose
j'attends la 2e levée il faut ajouter
mon 7e avec à l'acte moi même j'ai
attendu j'ai 39 ans était attendu je
suis était sur une liste et voila
mais ça c'est le problème le
gouvernement ils ont tous l'âge de
guillaume genton tous est avec la mère
de sa schalbach de quoi oui j'ai lu
verde oui mais ça j'entends bien
monsieur sait que c'est parfait le pass
annie terre mais moi je ne suis pas
vacciné je ne veux pas être vaccinés
donc je n'ai pas pas sanitaires donc je
ne peux pas voyager je ne peux pas
passer un bel été
alors si si passifs non mais j'insiste
parce que les mots anthony à oui c'est
pas un passe lui ne s'est pas un pass
maximale ces impasses anita werther donc
si vous n'avez pas le vaccin vous pouvez
faire un test est aujourd'hui parce
qu'on me dit vous mettez des contraintes
mais on enlève des contraintes
parce qu'aujourd'hui si vous voulez
aller en espagne vous devez faire un
test dit de toute façon donc vous aurez
pas une contrainte en plus bien sûr et
ceux qui sont vaccinées parce qu'ils
peuvent ou pas
veulent ils peuvent montrer le vaccin à
partir du 1er juillet dans toute
l'europe il y aura le même code le même
qu air code que vous avez vus à l'écran
il sera harmonisée ce sera le même lu
par le même lecteur le douanier etc
il sera reconnu partout en europe et
nous on commence dès demain alors oui
les options sur la photo du psn et dire
qu'on a vu je voyais un drapeau
américain drapeau chinois quand on
pourra voyager en dehors de l'union
européenne c'est ça alors les biens la
question voilà ça c'est une très bonne
question nous ça dépend un peu des
autres
bon nous à ce que je vous ai dit c'est
les règles d'une main pour accueillir
par exemple demain un américain vaccinés
s'ils prouvent qu'il est vacciné il n'y
a pas forcément de même parce que nous
mais il peut avoir un papier il peut
rentrer en france à partir de demain
s'ils prouvent sa vaccination
un américain c'est mon iphone r 1000 ou
est ce qu'on peut emmener où l'on ne
peut pas encore allé aux états unis on
est en train de négocier avec eux et
négocie avec quelques pays pour qu'il
reconnaisse nos vaccins ne passe c'est
un pas que ça me tenait bien sûr mais il
se trouve que ils ont pas on n'a pas
complètement en avait que pour l'instant
le ils reconnaissent pas mais la semaine
prochaine il y aura une réunion
politique entre l'europe et les états
unis on espère qu'ils vont reconnaître
les français les européens
j'espère à partir du mois de juillet
mais je crée une tension de haut niveau
voisin ce qu elle pour aller en israël
alors je vais vous pourrez pour être
très clair et pour pas vous dire de
métier nous on reconnaît ce qui son pays
vers israël c'est à dire que la
situation sanitaire est bonne on
reconnaît quelqu'un un français qui est
en israël aujourd'hui en israël et à qui
les enfants s'ils peuvent venir avec sa
preuve de vaccins à partir de demain en
israël aujourd'hui ils reconnaissent pas
encore pour nous ils demandent des tests
etc
si vous avez le moindre doute parce que
je sais que les gens exposés des
questions très concrètes pays par pays
on a presque 200 vous allez il ya un
site je suis concret c'est très bien
c'est très bien fait qui s'appelle
diplomatie.gouv.fr sept sites de mon
ministère et vous pouvez regarder pays
par pays s'est actualisée presque tous
les jours ils vous disent il faut un
test il faut un vaccin si reconnu que
c'est un bas vous irez tiffany moins
puisqu'elle a trouvé l'amour voilà oui
et ça change parfois d'un jour à l'autre
donc avant vos vacances quand vous
réservé de schiste l'amour pontife a du
bon temps le
justement vous disais ça change tous les
jours alors je ne parle pas de justement
de lieu à l'intérieur de nos frontières
européennes
mais en revanche à l'extérieur il ya des
gens qui ont pris on m'a envoyé des
messages à des gens qui ont pris par
exemple des vacances et qui ont déjà
d'ores et déjà réservé leurs vacances
notamment au maroc ou en tunisie et qui
ne savent plus du coup à quel saint se
vouer parce qu'ils ne savent pas si ils
y ont droit ou pas s'ils peuvent y aller
ou pas s'ils seront en quarantaine ou
pas ils ont beaucoup de questions à ce
sujet alors on choisit pas pour les
autres
donc c'est eux qui disent quand il faut
y définissent les règles pour l'été de
la plupart des pays sont en train de
dire quelles sont les règles pour cet
été par exemple maroc tunisie on a
beaucoup de questions pour marouane ben
oui ils ont défini le maroc c'est déjà
le cas les règles pour cet été
aujourd'hui même quand vous êtes vacciné
il vous demande un test
d'accord mais on va y aller on peut y
aller on peut y aller il vous demande un
test et quand vous revenez en france
parce que c'est important
normalement les gens viennent comme
c'est un pays voyez sur la carte des
pays qui sont orange pour l'instant soit
vous êtes vacciné
ces bons souhaits parlant s'ils veulent
être vaccinés on vous demande quand même
un test pour l'instant si vous n'êtes
pas vacciné il faut une bonne raison
pour y aller on voit que on voit non
mais votre angleterre et en rouge est
enfin prêt à se compliquer
et ouais c'est vrai parce que c'est plus
l'union européenne et en plus il ya des
variants indien ils ont fait attention à
ça se complique depuis justement de
trois jours et qui avait nouveaux foyers
qui sont à passer pour ça si vous
regardez les chiffres
les taux d'incidence en angleterre si
c'est bon et ils ont bien vacciné un peu
plus vite que nous ouais mais ils ont
les variants indien donc on est prudents
les a pas mis en verre comme l'allemagne
l'espagne en revanche ça se passe les
réunions non sans merci c'est quoi alors
lucas ni au vin rouge chinoise et moi
alors messieurs
alors on a essayé de faire un peu mieux
merci clemenceau
il ya quand même un peu de cohérence
toute l'europe toute l'union européenne
et en vain crois que c'est anvers c'est
tout vu ça parce que on a les mêmes
vaccins
on va voir le pass sanitaires et la
situation s'améliore on voit que toute
l'amérique du sud et en rouge
oui parce qu'il ya la cordillère des
andes il ya beaucoup de violence y ait
beaucoup de barrières et il ya des pays
qui ont vacciné que le vaccin chinois
comme le chili beaucoup et s'aperçoivent
qu'ils s'interrogent pas complètement
voilées ça c'est interdit
justement il ya deux vaccins quand ils
vous ai dit tu devrais je pouvais rester
dans les missions qu'on vous a pas vous
mais vous présentez super tiens je suis
porte-parole du gouvernement
voilà donc que mal de rassurer un gars
quelqu'un il ya deux vaccins qui ne sont
pas reconnus c'est le chinois et le
spoutnik
alors il ya quatre vaccins c'est
important pour le passager interpellé à
85 qui sont reconnus cd4 qui sont
autorisés en france donc tous les
vaccins que les français ont pour cela
vacciner c'est bon on les rappelle
voilà c'est fait heures c'est moderna et
c'est johnson
c'est sa façon cd4 que vous avez en
france où l'accord alors si vous avez un
touriste qui est vacciné au vaccin
chinois ou vaccin russe aujourd'hui il
n'est pas reconnu
donc il rentre pas sauf s'il vient d'un
pays où on accepte un test d'accord le
vaccin tout seul non ça c'est sûr que
non d'accord c'est sûr pourquoi parce
que on les scientifiques nous disent on
sait pas s'ils sont assez protecteur et
quand on voit ce que celle hilare n'a
pas très envie de jouer avec son frère
très important oui monsieur bonne une
famille par exemple en espagne ou en
italie avec donc ils ont tous les deux
vacciner un film avançant tout les des
vaccinés les jeûneurs vacciner ça
commence à ses qualités de côté josé
alors josé ça dépend de l'âge de l'osé
non il ya 15 ans allez j'ose il a 15 ans
il est pas vaccinés en fait il en existe
donc toujours pcr ou antigénique ou pc
alors ça dépend du pays
donc ce n'est pas harmonisée par rapport
à l'europe non alors normalement à
partir du 1er juillet tests pcr ou
antigénique c'est bon les légumes entre
eux parce que parfois peut-être que josé
le partir ce week-end là je vous l
assure diplomatie où ses parents point
gouv.fr il fait espagne et il regarde
hockey camions en espagne vous n'êtes
quand vous êtes mineur vous n'êtes pas
vacciné test et si vous avez
moins de cinq ans seulement rien là même
qui accompagne vos parents ont reçu de
50 est alors une autre question gay
français l'imposent encore des
quarantaine pour les voyageurs y compris
français en provenance de certains pays
est ce que le pass il dispense des
quarantaines maintenant alors
intéressante mais pas pour l'instant ça
dépend des catégories je prends les pays
rouges pays rouges parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de variants brésil 1-2 chili et
c'est d'abord pour venir en france sauf
si vous êtes français a essayé de france
et d'être toujours une revenir en france
si un jour vous êtes vous toujours on
est sympa vous êtes français vous
revenez en france vous avez quand même
un test à l'embarquement
un test à l'arrivée systématique pour
tous les pays rouge est effectivement
quarantaine et c'est la quarantaine
qu'on appelle contrôle et on peut vous
appeler vous devez rester chez vous il
ya une question intéressante d'un
téléspectateur
prenez-en de la graine qui nous dit
est-ce qu'on va être remboursée si on
fait des tests à l'étranger pourra-t-on
oui on va ils ont mis 50 questions en
même temps mais qu'est ce que c'est que
ça c'est l'autre mais qu'est ce que
c'est assez logique et là en plus il est
derrière vous tenez qui a envoyé le tout
et il a duré
loïc voilà merci mon chéri alors on va
poser là excusez moi fou ou alors je
compte partir en espagne cet été et est
sortie de l'x outil gratuit là je suis
remboursées par la sécurité ça c'est
damien mccain ont alors ça il faut quand
même le dire parce qu'on a beaucoup
critiqué on est le seul pays en europe
avec le danemark où les tests sont
gratuits pour passer sa chance et non
depuis le début la sécu qui les paye
s'est jamais gratuit mais je veux dire
il n'y a pas de problème s'il n'est pas
d'argent si vous devez en faire beaucoup
vous avez le test gratuit en pharmacie
c'est rapide c'est douloureux mais c'est
rapide alors faire l'espagne c'est pas
gratuit
bref c est quand vous êtes un français
que vous êtes touristes quelque part en
espagne ou ailleurs vous avez droit
en revenant à un remboursement
forfaitaire pour que ces 50 euros donc
je vous ai dit quand même quand vous
êtes france et à l'étranger
il ya une question qui revient très
souvent c'est celle des masques ça fait
maintenant de longs mois qu'on en parle
qu'on est habituel porter deux dedans
comme dehors et certains espèrent que ça
ne va pas durer est ce qu'on va devoir
se balader avec le masque cet été on va
encore vous dire on sait qu'au mois de
juin
oui jusqu'à la fin du mois de juin c'est
sûr d'accord sur un format de joie c'est
sur manoire c'est sûr on va le garder en
extérieur à ce qu'ont fait les choses
progressivement faut quand même pas chez
tout faire gaffe
après on va voir on a dit alors il ya le
professeur delfraissy qui a dit oui oui
qu'il pensait que sade est compliqué il
faut dire aux français qui m'ont gardé
le masque préférence aussi et puis on
n'a pas envie mais pour l'instant
un dernier effort à partir de demain on
our y aurait dix jours c'est sûr
j'espère on va voir les chiffres s'il ya
bien sûr pas voir les chiffres là où les
terrasses et faut voir que ça ça dérape
pas si ça dérape pas je pense qu'on
pourra y aller mais on fera rendez vous
c'est comme pour les discothèques à la
fin nous a élevés en faveur des veaux la
fin du mois de juillet concevoir
discothèque il patinait avec le
président apparemment il a dit qu'il est
ce que tu as une belle course et sur les
boîtes de nuit et le faisais et pino des
vacances quand on part en vacances on
aime bien sortir en boîte de nuit
mieux pour l'instant c'est pas du tout
ce qui va se passer là on a dit que le
prêt dans l'âme tout à l'heure le 21
juin on regardera on peut se poser sont
les chiffres et on l'a ainsi on
annoncera si on peut pas tout ça pour
avec des règles des protocoles réouvrir
mais peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui
quand oui si on a une dose de vaccin et
on part en vacances on est donc à
l'étranger mais dans un espace schengen
est ce qu'on peut se faire vacciner sa
deuxième dose qui tomberait pic
entraîneurs étrangers en vacances dans
un autre pays ça franchement je
conseille pas parce que de façon
générale c'est très dur organisez vous
n'êtes pas sûr de pouvoir avoir un
rendez vous il y aura beaucoup de
touristes donc fait passeur on s'est
fait tellement des situations vraiment
parce que là c'est l'inter ou alors on
dirait le gaillard et on va réviser un
truc je le vois ce qu'il faut c'est bien
d'être faites pas ça ok on sait qu'elle
a essayé de je sais que c'est compliqué
en ce moment parce qu'on a tous nos
moments là la vaccination et puis voilà
donc on peut à l'espèce est un peu plus
mais franchement c'est plus sûr c'est
plus prudent de prendre le rendez-vous
deuxième dose la bouille est d'accord
oui gilles verdez j'ai vu que l'on
parlait d'ailleurs marqué c'était le
plus chiant g8 l'union européenne
parlait d'un certificat numérique
européen ça veut dire qu'il va faire des
supers contrainte
là on pourrait nous en poser des trente
ans il a réussi reçu donc le je vous dis
c'est le
c'est le même le code que vous avez là
partir de demain pour aller voir un
match de foot ou aller voir un match de
tennis
le 21 juin donc pour eux je mets tout il
se transforme dans votre application en
format européen et ce sera à partir du
1er juillet le même dans toute l'europe
ne devrait pas faire il n'y aura pas
deux applis de truc c'est le même truc
c'est wiimote pour soi et est ce que le
fait d'avoir une copie de récemment vaut
pas sanitaire puisque les gens qui ne
pourront pas se faire vacciner quand il
convient de partir est-ce que ça vous
est ce que ça vaut bien sûr lutter est
ce que ça vaut pas sanitaires alors si
vous avez le comité vous pouvez prouver
parce que le penser un test j'ai toyer
les avait eu une dose il est évident si
c'est si vous avez un test positif soit
positif curieux personnage plus de 15
jours ou de moins de six mois
donc normalement on estime qu'il ya
encore des anticorps d'accord là ça vaut
aussi donc il faut garder son ensemble
reste positive avec toi là d'accord
d'accord et si vous avez le convient de
commencer vous pouvez avoir une seule
dose de vaccin
on considère vous êtes complètement de
kiné